[Musique]
comme par le plus grand des hasards à
quatre jours des élections régionales on
nous annonce la fin du couvre-feu on
nous annonce la fin du port du masque en
extérieur peut-être va-t-on nous
annoncer je sais pas des baisses
d'impôts vous dit merci jean castex
merci emmanuel macron pas agi merci le
premier tour des élections régionales
je suis pas dupe rémy ça le sens du
timing
oui cette manière je suis passé de bonne
guerre il prend ses responsabilités et
je mens en tout cas qu'on puisse
honnêtement un peu respirer qui s'en
plaindra
si je faisais du mauvais esprit je
disais je dirais deux jours avant les
élections régionales
est ce un hasard vous y répondre et tout
le monde y répondre à ce qu'un rapport
je crois pas surtout je crois pas du
tout que les français puissent imaginer
qu'on adapte les règles ou que nous
faisions la pluie et le beau temps sur
l'épidémie en fonction d'une élection
territoriale enfin ça n'a pas de sens et
la question qu'on se pose c'est est on a
quelques ados la semaine prochaine parce
qu'un deuxième tour des élections
régionales donc on a forcément une bonne
nouvelle qui va arriver
l'épidémie s'est pas nos clients voici
des images que le ministre de
l'intérieur ne veut plus voir dans sa
note adressée au patron de la police
gérald darmanin réclament que soit menée
une cinquantaine d'opérations dans les
quartiers les plus impactés par les
rodéos urbains
si les ordres du ministre de l'intérieur
sont claires on procède à des
interpellations
si les procureurs généraux autorise les
perquisitions en fallait les visites
dans les caves et bien dans ce cas là on
va avancer si simplement une circulaire
pour dire saisissent et des manteaux
pour les détruire
on le fait déjà il s'agira notamment
d'identifier préventivement les lieux de
stockage de saisir systématiquement les
deux roues et les quads pouvant être
utilisés et d'initier des procédures
judiciaires pour identifier les auteurs
elle lève le poing en louboutin
c'est avec cette photo postée sur
facebook que la militante du collectif
la vérité pour adama assa traoré a
annoncé sa collaboration avec la marque
je vous remercie chaleureusement de
l'honneur que vous me faites en
m'associant à votre campagne pour
l'égalité et la justice pour tous on y
engageant votre prestigieuse marque
on parle désormais de la probabilité
d'une victoire de marine le pen seriez
vous à bah moi je pense que c'est
possible oui je pense que c'est dans les
jardins d'un ange évoqué jean michel
blanc coeur mais on ne peut pas
diaboliser la gauche et les écologistes
et et dédiaboliser l'extrême droite en
reprenant ses idées monsieur d'arman a
quand même trouvé trop molle à la marine
le pen sur l'immigration selon une
enquête csa pour ses news les français
sont 62% à se dire favorables à un
référendum pour limiter l'immigration
dans le pays
je pense qu'il faut chaque année que le
parlement décide d'un quotas
d'immigration comme dans plein de pays
est en effet pas une mesure des gogos
qui seront à ce serait si bien que
lassés de vivre avec des gens mauvais
notre homme a beau matin va chercher
compagnie et se met en campagne
l'ours portait la même des abonnés dû
quitter sa montagne tous deux parrains
cas surprenant se rencontrent en à
tournan l'homme peur mais que faire et
comment esquiver et comme ça ne vous
échappe pas je ne touche rien des sujets
qui sont régionaux donc je n'interfère
pas dans cette campagne je continue
simplement le travail pour la nation et
nos compatriotes
c'est évident qu'on avons maintenant un
président en campagne qui vient pas
vraiment aller raconte des français
puisque ne serait ce que pour aller de
paris
donc là la somme où il ya juste 100 km
et liaison directe entre 1 il décide de
prendre l'hélicoptère et d'être entouré
par des nombreuses forces de l'ordre
pour rencontrer en catimini des gens
triés sur le volet donc voilà comment ça
se passe
ah bah oui
[Musique]
elle a envie que ça sent l'ail donc
abbas et sa selle dame de la
technocratie tu vois il ya un moment
sublime et ya un pas il ya un truc à
respecter c'est comme la contrainte
chez la fontaine au milieu de la
contrainte il ya de la liberté